la parole est à notre collègue Laurence
Cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste
de la réforme des retraites le
gouvernement instrumentalisent la cause
des femmes en réalité c'est une réforme
contre les femmes elle ne corrigeant
rien les inégalités salariales de 28 %
les inégalités de pension de 40 % et
elle monte d'après votre étude d'impact
que les femmes devront repousser l'âge
auquel elles prennent leur retraite bien
plus tard encore que les hommes vous le
saviez et vous le saviez et vous le
savez donc depuis le début mais ça ne
vous empêche pas de continuer à tenter
de nous vendre le contraire il faut dire
que la majorité sénatoriale vous êtes
bien quelle triste et scandaleux
spectacle de Neyer avec l'utilisation de
l'article 38 du Règlement du Sénat qui a
bayonné l'opposition avec les droits
avec l'accord des droites Unis
républicain centriste et macronistes
votre réponse votre réforme est bien une
réforme de droite monsieur du soft alors
ma question est simple en ce 8 mars 2023
journée internationale de lutte pour les
droits des femmes allez-vous enfin
sortir du et renoncer à votre réforme
qui a mis encore hier des millions de
femmes et d'hommes dans la rue pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre du
Travail Monsieur Olivier du chope merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Laurence Cohen vous l'avez dit
nous sommes le 8 mars j'en ai
internationale des droits des femmes et
vous avez interrogé le gouvernement sur
le contenu de la réforme des retraites
pour ce qui concerne les femmes nous
l'avons voulu nous l'avons fait madame
la Première ministre l'adier tout à
l'heure la réforme que nous portons
apportent un certain nombre
d'améliorations des améliorations de
plusieurs ordres d'abord vous savez et
nous savons tous que la manière dont
nous avons envisagé de revaloriser les
plus petites pensions sera plus
bénéfique aux femmes qu'aux hommes
pourquoi est-ce que ça sera plus
bénéfique aux femmes causes hommes parce
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement mais j'y
reviendrai les femmes sont celles qui
ont les plus petites retraites dans
notre pays de la même manière nous
intégrons dans les trimestres retenus
pour calculer l'éligibilité que ce soit
au départ anticipé dans le cadre des
carrières longues que ce soit pour
l'égidité au minimum de pension un
certain nombre de cotiser au titre de
l'assurance vieillesse pour les parents
au foyer de la même manière nous sommes
ouverts à un certain nombre
d'amendements des amendements qui n'ont
pas pu être examinés à l'Assemblée
nationale qui sont déposées ici et qui
vont permettre de prendre en compte les
indemnités journalières versées en 2012
pour relever le niveau de retraite des
femmes qui vont permettre aussi
d'améliorer la situation des femmes et
des parents au sens le plus large sur
des sujets parfois très sensibles je
pense notamment aux devenir du calcul
des pensions de retraite en cas de perte
d'un enfant pour les familles qui ont
plus de trois enfants votre assemblée
est saisi d'un certain nombre de
propositions notamment des propositions
portées par le président retaille aux
permettant de surcoter les trimestres
acquis par les femmes une fois qu'elles
ont atteint la durée d'affiliation crise
et avant l'âge d'ouverture des droits et
je peux vous assurer que cette
proposition a un équilibre qu'il faut
regarder et qu'il faut regarder avec je
crois le plus d'ouverture d'esprit
possible et enfin Madame la présidente
madame la sénatrice pardonnez-moi c'est
pas la première fois que je vous
qualifie ainsi vous avez rappelé que
nous sommes le 8 mars et peut-être vous
avez gardé un certain temps pour me
répondre peut-être que nous pourrons
convenir ensemble en cette journée
internationale des droits des femmes que
la vraie inégalité de pension elle ne
n’est pas de notre système de retraite
elle n'est des inégalités
professionnelles et que c'est sur le
chantier de l'égalité professionnelle
tout au long de la vie que nous devons
porter tous nos efforts pour que les
pensions soient les mêmes entre les
femmes et les hommes
[Applaudissements]
c'est la journée du recul des droits des
femmes ce que vous nous avez dit ce sont
des contre-vérités la seule chose avec
laquelle je suis d'accord c'est qu'il
faudrait effectivement une grande loi
travail et l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes c'est mettre fin aux
inégalités salariales revaloriser les
métiers féminisés notamment les
aides-soignantes les auxiliaires de vie
tous les métiers du soin et du lien
ainsi que les personnels de propreté qui
ont manifesté ce matin devant le Sénat
faire cotiser un temps plein les emplois
à temps partiel
augmenter le taux d'emploi des femmes
autant d'argent pour les caisses de
sécurité sociale ça permettrait de
renflouer votre soi-disant déficit juste
qui justifie votre projet régressif
voilà une réforme de justice et
d'égalité pour les femmes une réforme
féministe en ce 8 mars les femmes sont
dans la rue pour le crier le peuple est
encore dans la rue que ça vous plaise ou
que ça ne vous plaise pas
[Musique]